[Applause]
thank you baby
[Laughter]
[Music]
I have a slight accent background
talking at the arse right rolling rocks
I am from South Korea so I'm a
southerner yah
what do things I like kpop and shooting
zombies communism what's it all about
I thought man kids will say communism
never works as if we didn't spend
billions of dollars and kill millions
and people to make sure we don't work
remember the one of Vietnam and Cuba
came up we're pretty anxious about it
not born again thought mean is about
works because whatever people control
the means of production they're
democratically like the leaders
mysteriously died in a small rubber boom
boys finds automatic weapons themselves
stop invading yourself stabilizing
yourself what you do the
I've got a confidence but you supported
any cloths these Republicans considered
communism which is whenever two or more
people gathered to do something nice
[Music]
small business one day you know just
doing my thing shoplifting let's shop uh
became a is like you're stealing from a
small business you're eating a small
business well typically I want even
smaller business the smallest business
could be mhm you give us other than me
but total is about balance gather weight
big business they're in the way they're
big business some of the little man to
win one I don't like how baby boomers
will be like Millennials just want free
stuff as if no one else wants free stuff
isn't that why you coupon who's with
these people and I want to pay for
everything how do I pay for love they
paid what I cannot pay for more things
so what's the deal with capitalism man
just honestly do you think is right that
eighty six people have as much wealth to
support that billion people I think
capitalism is fine do you want to do it
but
something everyone play your stupid game
I like fortnight other way to Grandma
play to her house and she recess until
either Danny or I die all right
see you next time and stick around
there's another Mike in like 20 minutes
Oh oh my god the land of plenty
oh that was hilarious